season 8 has been written quite a long
time ago at this point but we don't know
if this leaked script is true or not I
will point out any sentence that might
be out of the order as I did in my
previous video regarding the leaks for
the final season anyways if you don't
want anything to be potentially spoiled
it's time for you to close this video
the episode starts the Ptolemaic man
that's right a huge battle at Winterfell
in previous episode driving in grey
water watch all of them make a stop to
rest there and to discuss their strategy
to feed the night king for good inside
Graber watched the neeraj Jon Jamie
Brown add more Tyrion census Sam DuBose
Robin and Lord Royce discuss how they
will organize themselves before
splitting up
John proposes to evade the night Kings
attack from the Eyrie since the fortress
is very difficult to impregnate Tyrion
jokes that a night king only needs 10
good men to impregnate it but only Brown
gets the joke anyways their plan is to
set the remaining Lannister and Hali
army to defend Riverrun together with
Admiral Tyrion Jaime and Bronn when
dearie gets attacked first nat king's
army has to get lured into the bloody
gate and that's when the Lannister and
Hawley forces need to join the attack as
well let me just remind you of one
conversation between Petyr Baelish and
Sansa that occurred in the fourth season
while approaching the bloody gate of
their way to the Eyrie sense eyes close
finger is this the only way to the Eyrie
Baelish told her the mountains are
impassable if you want to get the diary
you have to go through the bloody gate
it doesn't matter how large your army is
if you attack this gate you do it on
this road three men abreast and get
slaughtered like goats
Littlefinger also added know your
strengths use them wisely and one man
can be worth ten thousand at first
glance this would seem to make the
numbers in the night king's army count
for nothing
Baelish is right the only way to dear is
go to the bloody gate because the
mountains are impassable for any army no
matter how large it is but is it
impassable for the army of the Dead
what mountains would claim pretty much
most of any army before it would manage
to cross them and even those who'd
managed to survive would have lower
battle performance due to exhaustion the
night king's army on the other hand
would have no problem crossing those
mountains the army of the day does not
need food and water nor can get tired
with this being said I don't see any
reason why wouldn't a king's army go
through the bloody gate to reach the URI
and therefore this part of the script is
either fake or just another Tyrion's
plan that will not go very well anyways
there's also stated that theone is being
commanded to take back Pike and
defending together with the Ironborn and
the remaining Norton armies I'm not sure
if it states that Theon has to defend it
against your own Greyjoy who the
disappoint probably be on his
way back to Pyke after bringing the
golden company to King's Landing or if
it says that he had to defend it against
the army of the Dead which would not
make any sense
the knight king's army cannot swim nor
does it possess a ships that would
escort them to Pike or at least not that
we are aware of enemies John snowden
remarks that are in the Hound have not
been seen arriving in greywater watch at
mirror sure's that Arya has not died but
simply disappeared when they were
trading from Winterfell sensory marks
that wherever she is she's saved with
the Hound John nonsense and Brienne to
join Robin and ginjury to the Eyrie
where they would probably be safer
John stays with Davos Jamie Jorah bran
Tyrion and dead marine Reverend John
Monson heirs to travel to dragonstone
together with very sunny sandy well he
also says that Sam and Gilly should
travel with her mr. Vulcan received bad
news when the mermen did not make it to
bear Island and has died the next shot
is our Ian the Hound traveling on the
Kings Road in the found complains to
Aria that she should have followed her
brother and sister and death she's a
stupid girl to travel alone in the north
now that the army of the Dead is around
or he answers the Hound that he should
not have stuck with her if he is scared
the content elsewhere that he knows she
is heading to King's Landing but he
doesn't understand why orestes that she
has to cross one last name of her list
The Hound laughs and asks Arya why she
is still holding that list since
everyone will die soon anyway
or a response that she needs to kill
Circe herself the count agrees and tells
that he has some unfinished business
with his brother as well who happens to
be sirs his personal guard the toward an
encounter by an old woman who's asking
after the king in the north
the hound says that an old woman should
not be alone in the woods to deny king's
army approaching the old woman says she
doesn't fear the dead
arya tells the woman she thinks Jon Snow
has shelled south probably to
Dragonstone
the old woman takes a look at Arya and
tells her that they have met before
Arya is puzzled about as the old woman
leaves let me just highlight that the
old woman would obviously be male Sanjay
who would come one last time to Westeros
and would also fulfill the prophecy she
said to Arya back in the third season no
Sanjay would take off her necklace and
would once again reveal her true form
it is a frail old woman who is
approximately 400 years old basically
Melisandre will return to Jon Snow and
her true form to play her role in the
Great War since no one has ever seen her
true form no one actually knows how she
really looks like and therefore John's
promise of having her hanged if he ever
sees her again would be avoided this is
something I already pointed out in
his videos even though I still don't
think those leak scripts for the season
8 are true in my opinion lsanty will
reunite with both John Inari at
Winterfell and he'll eventually get
killed upon revealing to them who she
actually is regarding will sanchez death
there are a couple of possibilities such
as mulsanne jerk having to reveal to Jon
Snow that she's an effect Melisandre in
order to convince him into her new
prophecies this would most certainly
lead to her death since Jon promised her
that if she's to return to the north
he'll have her hanged as a murderer
another possibility is a prophesied
meeting between Melisandre herself and
Arya which might lead to no sanchez
death
we know that Arya is dedicated on
decreasing the names on her kill list
and we also know that no sanchez name is
on that list considering all those facts
are you killing no Sanja most surely
doesn't seem to be out of the realm of
possibilities anyways back to the script
during the night the character said
greywater watch sleep in huts jack has a
conversation at Howland Reed asking if
he's going to travel with them to the
south since the White Walkers will
probably hit greywater watch soon let me
just stop it right here to say that this
sentence is just one more proof that
these league scripts for the season 8
are fake they're stated that Howland
Reed is being killed in the second
episode during the Battle of Winterfell
and yet now he somehow has a
conversation with John Snow at greywater
watch those legs being fake does not
mean Howland will not appear it just
means this is not how his role would be
played beside bran he's the only person
that witness John's birth and therefore
he still has a big role to play in my
few videos regarding howl V and Hubble
just now find out that John is in effect
illegitimate son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark I predicted quite a few
things that came true in the last season
we learned that John is Aegon Targaryen
in bronze flashback but John still
doesn't know anything back then I said
that John learned the truth in the final
season which is when Howland Reed would
appear and not only that he would
confirm it but there's also a
possibility that he would prove it with
some object related to his show
parentage anyways let's just skip this
whole conversation between Helen and
John to see if there's any part of
League script that actually makes sense
it says Khyber visits her she informs
her that Winterfell has been attacked
and the Daenerys and John have lost a
great deal of their armies Cersei smiles
Qyburn also tells that the Lannister
army has apparently joined the battle at
Winterfell
Cersei asks if Jaime has arrived but
Coburn tells he doesn't know sir said
that he shouldn't have
after that urine arrives back in King's
Landing he comes hotel Cersei that the
golden company successfully took storms
and that the army is gathered right
there it'll sir see that it's time for
him to finally receive his reward and
Circe agrees it's still night in great
water watching the characters stay there
until morning John and Daenerys sleep
together in the hut Daenerys finally
tells John that she's pregnant with his
child
John's surprised and expresses his
happiness towards Daenerys he jokes that
this is the only good thing that
happened to them at the moment
he also knows about their child's health
since their family the nurse comforts
John the Targaryens have been in
breeding for years and she is perfectly
healthy the nearest thinks she's having
a son again and asks John what he would
name their son John thinks he should be
named after the greatest person he knew
in his life the one that saved his life
his Uncle Ned he wants his son to be
named at our Targaryen the nurse repeats
the name and smiles she says she likes
it very much
the two start to kiss in their Hut Jaime
visits Bryan Scott as well Brienne
grieves over Portuguese F telling him
that Podrick was the last person to
deserve to die like that
Jaime agrees telling Brienne that he was
a good lad and he was lucky to have been
around Brienne all that time the hound
and Arya make a fire during the night
The Hound asks how she managed to cross
off almost every name on her list
but before Arya can respond on that
question she tells the Hound to shut up
she hears some strange noises not much
later a group of whites attack Arya and
the Hound the two begin to fight whites
but more whites come since they're
attracted to the noise it's then when
Amira and the much larger pack of wolves
come in between and kill off a huge
amount of whites a lot of wolves die too
when most of the white circle of the
Hound things they should flee as soon as
they came before another group of whites
comes to kill them off Orion notices
that she has lost the needle during the
fight but the Hound insists that there
is no time left to search for the sword
and they should leave immediately this
time Arya manages to heaven Amelia
follow her and the Hound I most
definitely think that the media will
reappear in the time of the greatest
need to save our is life but it still
doesn't make me think that those leaks
are even partly accurate since there are
so many inconsistencies and to be honest
it sounds quite bad for the episodes
that are going to be the most expensive
episodes in the show ittan states that
the wedding between Cersei Lannister and
your own gray jury takes place in the
throne room urine looks very delighted
Cersei not so it's Chiron who has the
married sir severs tied long black dress
she looks quite sad during the wedding
the wedding scene itself doesn't take
long and sin switches to their wedding
bed this scene is an inn
between Cersei enduring having
intercourse and Jaime and Brienne also
having intercourse in their Hut that
they'll still think of each other next
morning the group departs from greywater
watch and John sends us a goodbye to
each other John asks ginjury to keep his
sister safe the nursing journals say
goodbye and leave each other the nurse
tells John that John should stay with
him
they'll need him to fight the night king
the talk is before leaving each other
Jorah is still having difficulties with
that we see all of the characters go
different face and that's how the
episode ends very heavy guys highly
requested leaked script for the third
episode of the final season that seems
just as fake as ever leaked script of
the next episodes